oh my god why the only what tongue feel  weird why is it fizzy  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  passion about fruit I'm a fruit lover a  fruit advocate I think fruit is nature's  candy okay I'm just eating fruit you're  making me nervous  what's different about those is there  something in it let's try this one just  pop it in oh my god why do they all make  what tongue feel weird it's kind of  fizzy okay that one's really busy  is it like alcoholic it tastes normal  but when I bite into it there's this  immediate tingly sensation did you give  me like bad fruit  it tastes a bit like sprite but like not  sweet yeah the cake is like a sour kick  like the Orangina soda like in fruit  okay ooh I like that yeah for a second  there I thought you poisoned my fruits  that's like molecular gastronomy right  there people need to stop messing with  fruit just leave it alone it's delicious  all by its little fruity self can I try  the strawberry